President Biden said that he hoped to
avoid chaos and confusion at the border
but that is exactly what I've seen today
and what I continue to see here this
evening I'm at the border between San
Diego and the United States and Tijuana
in Mexico the two countries are
separated by two 30-foot tall fences
topped with barbed wire and over recent
days and weeks a makeshift campsite has
emerged between these two fences to
account for the growing numbers of
people arriving here hoping to gain
access to the United States it's
obviously dark here now but have a look
at the pictures that we took just a few
hours ago in daylight hours they show
Growing numbers here volunteers on the
United States side of the Border handing
out nappies water Sun cream through the
fences people have been playing bin bags
tarpaulin sheets cardboard boxes
whatever they can get their hands on to
the fences to try and create some
shelter from what is baking heat here
during the day embracing cold at my
people have come here from all over the
world everyone has their own individual
story their own reason for seeking
asylum in the United States I spoke for
example to a couple of women from
Jamaica a gay couple who said they
couldn't live freely in their own
country and that's why they're coming to
the United States I also spoke to a
Catholic Family in Jordan they've been
on the road for two months a harrowing
journey in order to arrive here they've
been here for several days say they've
had little food or water from
authorities they say that they're
fleeing religious persecution many of
the people I've spoken to uh think that
the lifting of title 42 will make it
easier for them to get into the United
States amid this uncertainty though the
Biden Administration is desperately
trying to deter people from traveling to
the board this evening the Secretary of
Homeland Security
tweeting just an hour ago do not believe
the lies as Smugglers the border is not
open but thousands of people are already
here thousands more on their way